[Music]
in extremely fertile news submitted by
Cherry Coke a woman with 44 kids has
finally found a way to stop giving birth
44 well what do you mean she finally
found a way which you couldn't figure it
out before she kept trying to having
guys not in her and she's like maybe
they'll stop me from having kids I guess
that doesn't work or maybe a guy just
nuts once and that produces eight kids
with her Oh
could be something reduce the whole city
oh [ __ ] you know some people they eat
one burritos but they can have like four
shits that's true how the [ __ ] did you
have forty four even if you had a baby a
year since the time you were born
you'd be in the your mid-40s was she
ever not pregnant but then that means
she had babies at sixty she was shooting
doubles and triples she's doing serious
multiples Oh what is he 39 years old oh
she's giving her son like quadruple 84
can we interview her it should consider
assault mom like a fully automatic
assault mom only sure you called her mom
and out of vagina well I respect the
whole human yeah I love that so her name
is Miriam she's from Uganda and she has
you gone to have a baby you gotta have a
baby he's stupid no so right now she has
38 kids but she gave birth to 44 she
lost six that's a good ratio Jesus
throwing that away is crazy
she lost six would volume only had 38
three dozen I wonder if Babur on the
ground so she's had two children that
were single births six set of twins four
sets of triplets and three sets of
quadruplets
watch drupelets how many sets of
quadruplets three sets
oh this lady is a champion breeder dog
same dad yeah so that's a lot of girls
have a nice
no me yeah do all the kids look similar
okay so I'll show you the first photo
these are all brothers Oh fun
they live in poverty she [ __ ] popped
out the whole village dude 12 how fun
and then they live in poverty was pretty
nice I know I like that was before she's
I think she is it that bad though
because if everyone around you is in
poverty like it doesn't cause that much
sadness did you know that crime rates
and [ __ ] like that only happened when
there's a huge disparity so if the whole
damn community is poor in perspective
that's nice yeah is everyone able to eat
food um so she worked really hard to
provide for her kids so here's the story
so she was if you have 44 brothers and
sisters are you allowed to date them now
what are you talking about I'm asking
for the people with lots of family
science hat on bro tell us the rest of
the story I wanted to tell you guys cuz
it by that time your brothers and
sisters might feel like strangers this
is like why I'm in the car with my dad
and he's just talking about some car bar
and I was like yeah hey West Virginia
it's okay but I don't know about
Rhonda's who kinda can't do that
that it makes sense now okay keep going
keep going please so when she was 13
years the whole she her parents dropped
her off at some man's house and called
it marriage and so he's he was 27 years
older than two 14 13 she oh he was 27
years older she's in 40s yeah so fresh
house girl gross
so then a year later biologically you
think sure I'm not saying she's hot oh
no you said she was fresh she's hot off
the press I get why is that nasty well a
wrinkled old raisin is nasty he's seen
this the seals still on it - yeah it's
not me but the 27 parts weird because
when I was in Thailand this MOG village
they would marry the kids around 13 14
but the guys that they're marrying are
16 and then they get married but they
might not live together they might not
[ __ ] until a couple years later well she
had her first set of twin like her first
babies which were twins
the
next year after she got married and then
triplets and then another year there
were quadruplets
so 14 15 16 and hogweed triplet nine
kids or whatever it is yeah
whatever methods so then she was saying
that like her husband was very abusive
beat her anytime she would like have
like an idea he didn't like and he would
always spend a lot a lot of time away
from home we are not going to have a
cheer camp I'm not going to do that
you stupid very personal so this guy
wanted to have a sugar cane his jess has
Ugandan roots yeah let's just have to do
that easiness yeah no one brought her up
yeah ridiculous dreams
you cannot play the piano yeah so anyway
so this this her husband is a deadbeat
because she would also spend a la a lot
of time away from home he never ever
actually you'll have already had was
naming is this I'm trying to talk over
I'm trying to listen over what do you
want me to say nothing you know you know
what it's like it's like I'm trying to
focus on something but I have like a
college party in front of me yeah it's
like the concentration game in active
weather was like my Ron you have to like
stay focus on listening to Bob listening
oh that's a game that yeah I could be a
pro every time I dedicate if I'm
listening you're seen nonsense no I'm
agreeing with her I'm just really trying
to distance if he's listening um hey
could the kids all marry each other
[Laughter]
I'm still a good girl over here Thank
You Gio you gonna start yay okay do I
get a star no shut up anyway samarium
she has learned many different skills
trying to provide for her family so she
collects lope local herbs to sell she
bakes cakes she lays bricks braids hair
organizes and decorates events and even
smiles hair for brides so she is just
trying her best to get her kids to have
a better life than she had because she
says like the for her like her message
to other parents is my back trying to be
good [ __ ] hard it is not to mention
this [ __ ] you're just thinking about how
they're all in poverty right tip said
she said she's just check I said it
first and it sounds like how fun cuz I'm
thinking a house full of kids and then
she goes and they live in poverty so I'm
like okay well you thought so this she
discovered how to not be pregnant right
yeah so I wanted to get there but yeah
it wasn't it wasn't for that it wasn't
that reason good job yeah this is the
really the one that's gonna make you
want to subscribe she went to the doctor
the doctor says she has a high ovary
count which means any procedure would
put her health and even her life in
danger but eventually somehow they don't
tell me how the doctors were able to cut
her uterus so she's not able to get
pregnant anymore that's why she finally
stopped having kids three years ago and
also because the husband left but that's
the main thing cuz the sperms not there
yeah Boston no but you know what this is
confusing though because the oldest
child is 23 years old and he says he
hasn't seen his dad in in 10 years so
I'm like how did
he like Polly isn't [ __ ] when the kids
are awakened like watching maybe you
guys only there to [ __ ] he comes in he
beats her ass he [ __ ] her he leaves
like the kids don't see him well no he
then he offers a name he's I think Billy
this time what an awful idea that's what
makes so much sense why she's like I
want to provide my kids with ya know her
message thing was she was saying like
she did she will never abandon her kids
because that's what her parents did to
her so she says like she says stop
selling your daughters from men for
early marriages they suffer too much and
the loss of parental love is something
that they can never fully recover oh
yeah heartbreaking recover now she could
build the army with her whole children
yeah she could find that son of a [ __ ]
and beat his ass yeah she should do that
and she could build a whole company know
about knives
oh yeah don't whittling the knives find
your daddy and kill him game and think
yeah I mean she has all those farm hands
now and she could actually build a
sugarcane farm that she always wanted
she could mother of children's yeah and
be dragons it'd be easy to find you
because he's the only person in the
whole village that sounds like all
schwarzenegger family wait as you saying
that i wonder if her first born twins
became a nurse and the other became a
qualified builder so she's like trying
to like in the rest are the mafia helped
her kids achieve her dreams cuz they're
saying that they all have big dreams
like being doctors lawyers so she was
like i want them to achieve these dreams
something i was not able to do where's
the go fund me I wanna can we replace
some of those kids and bring them to
America and then send some of our kids
over there like a exchange program once
um the [ __ ] ones that want to be
youtubers let's go in dr. Phil if they
have a tick tock account just yeah that
ship all the kids on tick time and they
could they could try to make a starting
point
yeah important good sorry plan I think
that's a desert dope idea it's like an
exchange program well she does say that
children are a gift from God
tick tock er any tick doctors anything
she'll raise all the tick tock children
get from God she's had a couple of
Christmases brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]